[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER: All
right, let's get started.
Today, we are going to complete
our discussion of consumer
choice by actually coming
back and deriving the demand
curve that we started
the semester with,
actually showing you how
from the limited set of tools
we've given you we can actually
derive the underlying demand
curves that we
see in this class.
I'm going to spend the rest
of lecture then talking
about the elasticity of demand--
what determines the shape
of that demand curve.
I'll talk about how changes
in income affect demand.
And then, we'll
come back and talk
about the effects
of a price change,
and we'll talk about
the theoretical concepts
underneath how you
analyze a change in price
in economics model.
So let's start with
deriving demand curves.
So we started in this class
with the demand supply curve,
and I said we'd tell you
where they came from.
So, basically, we're
now going to talk
about how do you derive,
from the tools we've
learned so far, the
relationship between price
and quantity demanded--
the downward-sloping
relationship
between price and quantity
demanded that we showed you
in the very first lecture.
So to do so, let's return to
our example from last time.
Remember, our example
from last time
is utility function was of
the form u equals P times c.
Your parents had
given you an income
of $72 with which you could
buy pizza and cookies, pizza
at a price of $12 and
cookies at a price of $6.
That was the parameters in
are example from last time.
And once again, remember, all
I've done is giving you stuff
here.
Obviously, this part
is non-controversial
as a price for pizza in the
market, the price of cookies
in the market.
There's an income that's
the amount of money
your parents give you.
That's all non-controversial.
And this is just a
sensible assumption
of what someone's
preferences might look like.
All I'm saying is with these
four things, we are done.
With these four things, we
can now derive a demand curve.
And how's that?
Well, let's start by looking at
it graphically in figure 4-1.
Figure 4-1, on
the left-hand side
is exactly the kind of a
difference curve analysis
that we did last time.
So we start with
budget constraint bc1.
That is something
where you can either
get up to 12
cookies and no pizza
or up to 6 pizzas
and no cookies.
And we know, from our
analysis last time,
given this we showed
you last time,
and you went home and practiced
and were so excited you told
your mom and
everything, we told you
how you could show
that you'd want
6 cookies and 3 slices of
pizza at a point like point a.
We showed that last time.
Now, we also talked about
how when the price changes.
So, for example, imagine
that the price of cookies
rises to $9.
Well, we know if the price
of cookies rise to $9
is that you could still, on
your budget, afford 6 pizzas.
So the y-intercept
does not change,
but the x-intercept changes.
Now, you can only afford 8
cookies, so you move to bc2 sub
2.
You used to be able
to afford 12 cookies,
now you can only
afford 8 cookies.
And most importantly, the
slope of the budget constraint
has steepened.
Remember, what is the slope
of the budget constraint?
The slope of the
budget constraint--
the slope is minus P c over Pp.
That's the slope.
And that steepened, because
the price of cookies has risen.
So you have a steeper
budget constraint.
The slope used to be minus
1/2, now it's minus 3/4.
So now, that's gone from
minus 1/2 to minus 3/4
with this new higher
price for pizza--
higher price of cookies.
I'm sorry.
The price cookies rose to $9.
That budget constraint
has steepened.
What does this do to
demand for cookies?
Well, we find the highest
tangency of your indifference
curves with this new
budget constraint,
and you could solve
mathematically
to show that that will occur at
point b, where you will choose
to continue to have
3 slices of pizza
but to only have 4 cookies.
That is what happens
if you take this,
you do constrained
optimization--
if you change this price to 9,
re-optimize the way we showed
you last time,
you'd end up finding
that you would want 3 slices of
pizza and 4 cookies at point b.
Now, what if instead the
price of cookies fell to $4?
So cookies got cheaper.
Well, in that case,
now, you could still
only afford 6 slices of pizza.
So the y-intercept once
again doesn't change.
But the x-intercept
now moves out to 18,
because now you can
afford 18 cookies.
So your new budget goes
straight is flatter.
It's bc sub 3.
It's the flatter, outermost
budget constraint.
Your opportunity
set is much larger
because cookies are cheaper.
You have the same amount
of money from your parents,
but it can buy more stuff,
and you can buy more cookies.
so your opportunity
set is larger.
So you now can re-optimize
with a now flatter budget
constraint.
The slope, instead of being
1/2, has now fallen to 1/3.
When the price of
cookies is $4, the price
of cookies over the price
of pizza is now 1/3.
So an absolute value,
the slope is lower.
So you can now-- and we say that
if you take the same utility
function and optimize
at the new price,
at a price of cookies
of $4, you will find
that you will choose point c.
Still 3 slices of pizza,
but now 9 cookies.
So all three of those
points we simply
did by redoing optimization
I did last time--
by taking this utility
function, maximizing
it subject to a
budget constraint
dictated by these parameters.
And all I did was change
this parameter twice.
Once I changed it up.
Once I changed it down.
Questions about that?
Well, you've now
derived a demand curve.
Oh, yeah, I'm sorry.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Will this also
change the indifference curve?
JONATHAN GRUBER: No,
your indifference curves
are determined by
utility function.
Your difference
curves do not change.
It changes which
indifference curve
you end up choosing, because
the tangency point changes.
But the only way to change
the indifference curve
would be to change
utility function.
Indifference curves purely
come from this part of it.
So indifference curves come
from here, budget constraint
comes from these three pieces.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it
possible [INAUDIBLE]
logical for different
indifference curves
in a quite long-range
component, is that possible?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well, no.
But it is possible to take
a bunch of demand curves
and conglomerate them
to get one demand curve.
And I'm going to talk
about that later.
But, no, indifference curves
you can't really add up.
Because, remember,
utils are not a thing.
So you can't add up
indifference curves.
But if we want to add up people,
you would add up demand curves.
And we've now derived
the demand curve.
How have we done that?
Well, what's a demand curve?
It's the relationship
between price and quantity.
Well, I just showed
a relationship
between price and quantity.
When the price goes down,
quantity of cookies goes up.
When the price goes up,
quantity of cookies goes down.
Well, you just shift over to the
right-hand side a figure 4-1.
there's a demand curve.
I just graphed
these three points,
I just graphed, for each
of the different price
of cookies I gave you, how
many cookies are demanded.
Well, at a price of cookies
of 6, our initial price--
geez, this is really small--
6 cookies were demanded.
When the price of
cookies goes up to 8--
I'm sorry, when
it goes up to 9--
only 4 cookies are demanded.
When the price of cookies
falls to 4 at point c,
then 9 cookies are demanded.
So literally, we've just
derived the demand curve.
Starting with these primitives--
your tastes, your preferences--
and your budget constraint,
we've derived a demand curve.
And That's it.
That's where demand
curves come from.
And that's essentially what is
underneath the demand curve.
What's underneath
the demand curve
is the fact that the reason
to demand curves slope down
is that as the price goes up,
you want less of the good.
Because with the given utility
functions, that price goes up,
you want less of the good.
And that's why demand
curve slopes down.
So we've just derived that.
Questions about that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it always true
that regardless of your utility
function, you will always
want three [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Great question.
Did you peek at my notes?
No.
Because if you
had, you would have
seen that's exactly the
question I would have asked you.
So since you asked
me, I'll answer it.
No, it is not always true.
In fact, that is a feature
of this particular utility
function I've chosen.
This particular utility
function I've chosen
gives the feature that
the demand for a good
is a function only of your
income and that good's price,
not of the other good's price.
That's a feature of this.
That's why we like
this utility function.
It has that nice feature.
In general, that's not true.
In general, when the
price of one good changes,
it will affect the demand for
all goods, not just that good
itself.
So with a more general
utility function,
that would not be true.
With this utility
function, it gives
what's called the flat
price consumption curve--
not a term you need
to know, but just
if you want be more technical.
Which is basically, with
this utility function,
demand for any good is a
function only of its own price
and your income.
Therefore, when
other prices change,
it doesn't affect the
demand for that good.
But that is not generally true.
In general, when you change
the price of one good,
demand for all goods changes.
Questions about that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this why it shows
3 as a constant, and just--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Oh, it
wouldn't have mattered
what number I'd chosen.
But the bottom line
is as the price
of cookies changes, the
number of pizza slices
would never change.
Demand would never change.
That's a feature of this
particular utility function.
It's a nice feature of it.
Once again, that comes to
this trade with modeling.
I've chosen a simplified utility
function with this nice feature
that's almost
certainly not true.
But once again it allowed us to
derive a very sensible demand
curve without introducing
other complications.
Now, this demand curve's
particular shape,
what determines the shape
of this demand curve?
And that leads us to the second
topic I want to cover today,
which is the
elasticity of demand.
What determines the
shape of a demand curve
is what we call the elasticity
of demand, which we define
the elasticity of
demand, epsilon,
as delta Q over Q
over delta P over P.
It's the percentage change
in quantity for a percentage
change in price.
So, for example,
if quantity falls
by 2% for every 1%
increase in price,
that's an elasticity
demand of negative 2.
So elasticity of demand,
as long as demand curves
are downward-sloping,
is less than 0.
Because the price goes
up, quantity falls.
So elasticity of
demand is less than 0--
I'm sorry, less
than or equal to 0.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this the
change in quantity
over the new quantity
or the the old quantity?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Great question.
When we're doing this,
if we did it in calculus,
it would be infinitesimal
epsilon change.
So it wouldn't matter if
it was new or old quality.
When you do it discreetly,
use the old quantity.
So I should say, Q0 and P0.
Once again, if you
did this in calculus,
which is the way
we're sort of thinking
about in our
underlying intuition,
it's an epsilon change.
So Q0 and P0 are epsilon.
It doesn't really matter.
But if you do it discretely,
you'd want to use Q0 and P0.
These are great questions.
Keep them coming.
Now, whenever we think
of constant elasticity,
it's always useful to
think about the extremes.
So what are the extremes
of this measure?
One extreme would be if the
elasticity demand was 0.
We would call that
perfectly inelastic demand.
It would be epsilon equals 0.
Now, extremes never
exist in the real world.
But there are cases
that come very close.
So can someone, without flipping
the page of the handout--
don't do it, because before you
flip the page of the handout--
give me an example
of a good that
might have perfectly, in a very,
very, very inelastic demand,
where no matter the price, you'd
still want the same quantity.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Water.
You have to consume it to live.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Water-- something
that's essential
to life like water.
What else?
Yeah, in the way back.
AUDIENCE: Insulin.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Insulin is
the classic example we use.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sewage removal.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Sewage
removal is interesting.
Although, not quite, because
we see a lot of variation
around the world
in sewage removal.
But something like that--
basic essentials of life.
Insulin's a class
example we use.
Indeed, that's the example I
do you use in the next-- oh,
I guess I didn't
list it ion here.
So you could have
turned the page.
We think about perfectly
inelastic demand-- someone,
once again for those
of you who don't
know about the medical
science here, basically,
if you're diabetic, you have
trouble controlling your blood
sugar.
Insulin is a medicine
you need to take to help
you control your blood sugar.
Without it, you die.
So you'd think that's
pretty inelastic demand.
Like, I want to
live, so I'm going
to want to have my insulin.
And if the price
goes up, I'm not
going to say, nah,
I'll just die.
You're going to want to
still have the insulin.
So we think in
that case, quantum
would be fixed at some Q, which
is insulin you need to live,
and it wouldn't really
matter what the price is.
So your elasticity would be 0.
You have a perfectly
inelastic curve.
Quantity would not
change with price.
Basically, that would
happen when there
is no plausible substitute.
The reason water is not as
good as insulin is because I
can drink something else.
And sewage removal,
I can do other things
to deal with the
sewage in my house.
But insulin, there
is no substitute.
I die.
So basically, the
bottom line is,
when there's no
plausible substitute,
demand will be
perfectly inelastic.
Likewise, we consider-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can there be multiple
companies that sell insulin?
So if one, say,
increased the price,
they would shift to another.
JONATHAN GRUBER: OK,
but this is a market--
that's a great point.
I'm just doing this as--
let's actually image
just one company for now.
You're right, I'm not doing
choice across companies.
So that would be inelastic.
We could also do the other
extreme, perfectly elastic.
So what's an example?
Perfectly elastic
demand is that epsilon
equals negative infinity.
So what would cause
perfectly inelastic demand?
So people raise their
hand and tell me.
Perfectly elastic
demand-- I'm sorry.
What would cause
perfectly elastic demand?
What would cause it?
I'm just going to try to
spread it around a little bit.
You two have been--
Yeah
AUDIENCE: Would it be something
that's very unnecessary,
like diamonds?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
that's interesting.
I mean, that's not--
I'm going to come to that.
But that wouldn't-- that's
something where demand would be
less elastic, but not
close to perfectly elastic.
Because, basically-- well, let
me ask the question this way--
what would drive a good to very,
very elastic demand in general?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When it has
perfect substitution--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
Perfect substitutes.
Diamonds don't have
perfect substitutes.
I mean, we're increasingly
making fake diamonds that
are better and
better substitutes,
but a real diamond still doesn't
have a perfect substitute.
So what does?
What's an example of
something with a good--
with a very good substitute?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: A spork.
JONATHAN GRUBER: A spork.
[LAUGHTER]
There is no sub--
I am insulted that you would
suggest that the great spork!
You need two different
things to replace a spork!
AUDIENCE: You're never
using both at the same time.
So if the price
increases-- you never--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah.
But then you have to
buy a spoon and a fork.
No, I reject your
spork suggestion.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just joking.
No, but what else?
What else?
What is something that has
really good substitutes?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Off-brand medication.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah.
Something which is an
off-brand medication,
or I like to think
of a fast food,
like fast food burgers have
pretty good substitutes
with fast food pizza.
Basically, once again, it's hard
to think an extreme example.
Nothing's ever
perfectly elastic.
But things which have
very good substitutes--
typically this works well
when we think across brands.
If you think about
different brands of gum.
Jeez.
I mean, who the hell cares?
Or different brands
of fast food.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What about
something like a $5 gift
card, where after $5
nobody's going to buy it.
JONATHAN GRUBER: That's
a separate issue.
Let's come back.
That's sort of a
separate-- that's
like a weird, kinked
budget constraint.
That's not really
about substitution.
But the bottom line is-- we
don't need any more examples--
the key element-- and we
show that in figure 4-3.
That's going to be a
horizontal demand curve.
With a perfectly
elastic demand, you
have a horizontal demand curve.
And therefore,
price never changes.
It's sort of a
weird way to think
of perfectly elastic demand.
The way it works
is if I ever charge
a price 1 epsilon above someone
else, I'd lose all my business.
And if I charge a price 1
epsilon below everyone else,
I would have the entire market.
Because if it's
perfectly elastic,
like if one pack of gum--
I don't what-- these
stupid gum things--
Orbits and Ellipse
or whatever, if they
charge a penny more than
someone else, no would buy them.
They'd go out of business.
That's the idea here.
And that's why the
price can't change.
The price is fixed.
So if anyone deviates
from that price, boom,
they lose the whole market.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So wouldn't the
market for dollar bills
be perfectly elastic?
Like--
JONATHAN GRUBER:
There's not really
a market for dollar bills.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --dollar bills.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
There's not really--
I mean, you could say the
demand for cash in general
might be fairly elastic,
because you have credit cards
and things like that.
That's an interesting idea.
Yeah.
So, basically, when you have
perfectly elastic demand,
you end up with sort
of this constant price,
and quantity changes but
price doesn't change.
So that's kind of the extremes.
Now, in general, we have goods
that are more and less elastic.
In general, we end up with this
range between perfectly elastic
and perfectly inelastic.
The bottom line is-- here's the
intuition I want you to have--
what determines elasticity
is substitutability.
The more substitutable
goods are,
the more elastically
demanded they are.
So now, I want to go on to
another topic which is related.
Which is, we talked
in our example
about what happened
when I change prices.
What about when I change income?
So the third topic
I want to talk about
is what happens
when income shifts,
and how does that
affect demand curves?
When income shifts, how does
that affect demand curves?
Well, we could do the same
exercise we did before.
We did an exercise before.
We said, well, let's
just use the tools
we used before to solve
for you new choices
at different prices.
Let's just solve for you new
choice at a different income.
So let's go to figure 4-4.
Figure 4-4, once again
we start with bc1.
Same parameters as before--
same setup as before.
We choose point a.
Now, let's say I raise your
income from $72 to $96.
You've done well.
Your parents are
giving you more money--
$96.
Well, in that case
you will choose
to have both more
pizza and more cookies.
Given this utility function,
you will choose the point b.
You will choose point b.
Likewise, if I lower your
income from $70 to $48,
then you will choose point c.
So as your income goes up,
you'll choose more of both.
As your income goes down,
you choose less of both.
Now, once again,
you'll notice this--
well, let me come to that.
So basically, what that
says is I can trace out
the relationship between
how your income changes,
how you demand for
cookies change.
I can then graph that
on the next graph
and generate what's
called the Engel curve.
The Engel curve is
the relationship
between income and
quantity demanded.
And we'll come back
to why this matters.
The Engel curve is
the relationship
between income and
quantity demanded.
Now, here the Engel
curve is linear.
Once again, that's
just a feature
of this utility function.
In general, it doesn't
have to be linear.
But here the Engel
curve is linear.
That's just because of the
way we structured this utility
function.
And the slope of
the Engel curve is
what we call the income
elasticity of demand, gamma,
which is delta Q over Q--
Q0 once again, if we're
doing it discreetly--
over delta y over y0.
That's the income
elasticity of demand.
Now, let me just say one
comment here about this.
Because there's
sort of a big cheat
that I'm doing
here with all this
that I need you
guys to be aware of,
which is constant elasticity
versus linear curves.
We know a constant elasticity
curve will not be linear.
If it's linear, it's
not constant elasticity,
because if it's
linear, the elasticity
will change along the curve.
So the demand curve.
I just drew in
figure 4-1, that was
a constant elasticity
demand curve.
That's why it was curved.
This Engel curve I
drew here would not
be constant elasticity,
because it's linear.
You can calculate for yourself
that the percentage change,
the income elasticity will shift
as you go along this curve.
And you can show yourself that.
What we're going
to do in this class
is we're going to draw linear
constant elasticity curves,
which is, of course,
technically wrong.
Just think of them as blown
up versions of a large demand
curve.
Everything is locally linear.
Once again, for an epsilon
change, everything is linear.
So the truth is we'll
cheat a little bit
and often draw a linear
constant elasticity curves.
And I want to own
that that's a cheat.
But if everything
is really local,
it's not that bad a cheat.
So that's kind of
how we're going
to-- that's a cheat we're
going to do constantly
through this course.
And we'll be very clear--
we make clear any
problems or anything
if we need you to
deviate from that.
Now, what we have here, in
addition to a linear Engel
curve, is we have an
upward-sloping Engel curve
or positive income elasticity.
We call goods with a positive
income elasticity normal goods.
Goods where the more money
you have, the more of them
you want, we call normal goods.
Because that's sort of normal.
However, it is also true that
a number of goods in the world
actually have gamma less than 0.
And we call those
inferior goods.
Why would a good be inferior?
Why, when your income
goes up-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
Any examples anyone
can think of?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe at a
fast food restaurant.
The minimum amount of
food you have to eat.
And then, like,
[INAUDIBLE] your fast food,
and then I have to
get more money--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
Great example.
Yeah, in the back.
AUDIENCE: Omega watches
versus Rolex watches.
JONATHAN GRUBER: I wouldn't
think of either of them
as inferior.
Relative they may be inferior.
But, obviously, when
your income goes up,
you're not going to suddenly--
you're going to
want more of both.
Whereas fast food you
actually would want less of it
as your income goes up.
Literally, you will
eat at McDonald's less
if you're richer.
You're not going to have fewer
watches if you're richer.
So the bottom line is
that inferior goods,
you're actually getting--
it's a bit subtle.
You have different
goods of the same kind.
Let's think about classes
of goods rather than brands
of goods.
Once you get across
brands, you're right.
Let's think about
classes of goods.
Watches-- luxury
watches, in general--
are clearly not inferior.
Fast food may be inferior.
Literally richer people may
eat probably less fast food
than poorer people.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would something
like your refrigerator count,
where after you buy one you
don't really need more of them.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
that's like a quan-- that
could be right.
But yeah.
I think not, because
the bottom line
is rich guys are much
more likely to have
two refrigerators than one.
So it's a discreteness problem.
It's too discrete to
really use as an example.
But I think fast food
is a great example.
The class example
we use is potatoes.
Where in the old days,
before fast food,
that was the cheap, filling,
shitty-tasting food stuff
that guys sort of
ate all the time.
And now, when they
have money, they say,
I'm going to move on to steak,
and they eat less potatoes.
So something where
essentially you'd
rather shift to something
else if you have more money
is inferior.
Now, moreover, within
that, within normal, we're
going to draw a
distinction between what we
call luxuries and necessities.
Luxuries are going to be good
where gamma is greater than 1.
And necessities,
gamma is less than 1.
So we're going to say--
essentially, the
question is, proportional
to your budget, what happens
if your income goes up?
In other words, do you
spend more and more--
they're both normal goods.
The richer you are,
the more you buy of it.
But a luxury good is you
spend even larger share
of your budget on that
good as you get richer.
So that would be luxury,
like watches, boats, maybe
refrigerators, et cetera--
things where the richer you
get, the more of your budget
you spend on it.
Necessities are
things like food,
where clearly rich people spend
more on food than poor people.
But they spend a smaller
share of their budget on food
than poor people.
So it goes up, but doesn't
go up proportionally
with your income.
It goes up less in
portion with your income.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] for as
some sort of human necessities,
in the sense of if
you're more wealthy,
you might buy more name brand
food or something like that,
instead of more--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah.
Once we get into brands,
you can absolutely see that.
You can think of luxury
brands and necessity brands.
Absolutely.
But if we stay with
categories of goods,
then let's think of jewelry as
the [INAUDIBLE] example here
and food as the
canonical example here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
an example of something
that's near the border between
luxuries and necessities.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
You know, there is
a huge industry in estimating
these elasticities of demand.
So I'm sure there's
an answer to that.
I don't have it off of my head.
All right.
So now I've given you
the underlying tools
of consumer demand theory.
I've told you how to decide
what quantity a consumer wants.
I've told you how you can use
that to derive demand curve.
I've explained the shape
of the demand curve.
I then talked about what
happens as your income changes
and talked about the shape
of the income elasticity.
Now, I'm going to
put this together
to come back to revisit
something you think you already
know the answer to.
Which is, what happens
when a price changes--
the effects of a price change.
Now, you might say, well,
that's sort of silly.
We already did that
once this lecture.
We already did, when we
derived the demand curve--
the effects of price change--
we did some price
changes, right?
I showed you what happened as
the price of cookies change.
But, in fact, we
cheated a little bit.
We didn't cheat-- we gave
you sort of the bottom line
but didn't get into
the elements of why
people react the way
they do to price changes.
Now, we're getting in
some sort of deep theory.
Now, I'm going to
talk about something--
it's deeply theoretical
in the sense
that in some sense
if all you care about
is what happens
in the real world,
they just care about when
a price change happens how
does quantity change,
I'm going to use
some theoretical
concepts, which are going
to become very powerful
later on in the course, which
are important understand now.
Which is, how is the
underlying decision calculus
changed by price--
changed when the price changes?
And the way we're
going to do that
is that we're going to decompose
your response to a price change
into two effects--
the substitution effect
and the income effect.
We're going to separate your
response into two effects.
So the separation is going to
become very important later on.
The substitution
effect, we're going
to define as the change
in the quantity of a good
when the price changes
holding utility constant.
So it's delta Q--
d Q d p for shorthand-- but
holding utility constant
at some fixed level u bar.
The change in quantities
price changes--
so it's the
elasticity of demand--
but at a constant
level of utility.
The income effect is the change
in quantity of a good as income
changes.
Change in quantity, dy.
Which is the income
elasticity we talked about--
the change in quantity
as the income changes.
And this is actually multiplied
by the initial level of income.
We'll learn about
this in a section.
But that's technically how
the income effect is defined.
And you'll come into a
section about why that is.
But we're going
to decompose this.
So that's sort of confusing.
So let me start with
graphically to understand it.
So let's go to figure 4-5,
one of our more complicated
figures.
We start at budget
constraint 1--
same parameters as always.
All the math here--
all this graphic stuff
follows from the math
using that utility function
and these price and income--
same as before.
So we start, as
before, at point a.
Your tangency is the best
package you can have,
given that utility
function, is 6 cookies
and 3 slices of pizza.
Now, let's imagine the price
of cookies rises to $9.
The price of cookies in our
example goes from $6 to $9.
That's the example
we're going to analyze.
Now, we know from before
that will ultimately
move you from 6
cookies to 4 cookies
while holding pizzas
constant at 3.
So we know where you'll end up.
You'll end up at point c.
We did that before.
But actually two things are
happening to get you there.
The first thing that's happening
is the substitution effect,
which is the change in
prices with utility constant.
And how do we measure that?
We want to ask, given
that the price changed
but the utility is
constant, what's
the new quantity you choose?
What does utility constant
mean in this graph?
What does it mean to
hold utility constant?
Let's get some other
folks involved here.
What is it mean?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Same
indifference curve.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Same
So what we want to do is
ask, given the new prices
but the old indifference curve,
what quantity would you choose?
Well, the way we do that
is we find the tangency
between the new slope
of the budget constraint
and the old indifference curve.
And we do that by drawing
sort of an imaginary budget
constraint bc prime.
bc prime is a sort of
imaginary budget constraint.
It's not a real
budget constraint,
but it has the slope of
the new budget constraint,
but it's tangent to the
old indifference curve.
That's the key thing. bc
prime, the imaginary budget
constraint, the dashed line,
has the slope of the new budget
constraint, same as
the new price ratio.
So the slope is the
new price ratio.
The slope is at the
new price ratio,
but it's tangent to the
old indifference curve.
So bc prime is basically going
to the tangent [INAUDIBLE]
indifference curve at point b.
So what we're saying is the
substitution effect moves you
from point a to point b.
That is holding utility constant
but at these new prices,
you would choose to have
fewer cookies and less pizza.
We call this notion
compensated demand.
That is, I'm compensating you.
I'm holding utility constant.
I'm saying price of
change sucks for you.
You're worse off.
Your opportunity
set's restricted.
But I'm going to
compensate you by holding
your utility constant.
So call this compensated demand.
Your compensated
demand would mean
that when the price
goes up, you would
choose to reduce your
consumption of cookies
from 6 to 4.89.
Now, here's the key thing
about substitution effects--
we can sign them definitively.
They are always negative.
The substitution effect
is always negative.
The income effect
could go either way.
We'll show that.
The substitution effect
is always negative.
We can see this in two ways.
Graphically, think
about it this way--
you have to be tangent
to the same indifference
curve with a higher
sloped line, so you
have to move to the left.
If you get a tangent to
the same indifference
curve with a line
with the higher slope,
it's go to be to the left.
So that's a graphical intuition.
Mathematically, it's worth
writing out the steps,
because it helps.
That's why we teach
this, it helps remind us
of our consumer theory.
Step 1, you're at
this new tangency.
Step 2, we know that at any
such tangency that's optimized,
the marg utility of cookies
over the marg utility pizza
equals the price of cookies
over the price of pizza.
We know that's true
with any tangency,
because that's the
optimal choice.
Step 3, we know P
c over P p is up.
I just said that.
And this assumption is
the price cookies up.
Therefore, that leads to step 4.
Which is that M Uc
over M Up must be up,
because it's still equal.
Well, how do you raise the ratio
of the marg utility of cookies
to marg utility of pizzas?
How do you accomplish that?
By having fewer
cookies and more pizza.
So that means-- that implies--
that cookies are down
and pizzas are up--
and/or pizzas are up.
How do you get that
ratio to be higher?
Well, remember, this is
why do this math here.
Remember the key intuition--
more cookies means
lower marg utility of cookies.
The more cookies
you have, the less
you care about the next cookie.
So I want the marg utility
of cookies to be lower.
If the marg utility of cookies,
I'm sorry, to be higher,
I've got to have
fewer cookies, or I've
got to have more pizza, or both.
So the substitution
effect is always negative.
If I'm going to hold
utility constant,
and change prices,
and raise the price,
you'll always want
less of that goods
on the substitution effect.
Question about the
graphics of the math?
Now, let's come to
the income effect.
The income effect says,
holding prices constant--
so I shouldn't put this here.
The income effect is
this at a constant price.
I should have added that.
So the income
effect is the change
in quantity demanded
as income changes
holding prices constant.
So now we're saying--
the income effect is saying,
look, the price changed.
So therefore I shifted my
consumption away from cookies.
But the other thing that
happened is I got poorer.
Maybe I'd say you
didn't get poorer,
your parents didn't
send you less money,
but remember your
opportunity set restricted.
You effectively are poorer
because this price went up.
How do we represent that?
Well, we can exactly represent
that by the shift from bc
prime to bc2 Because bc prime
and bc2 have the same slope.
That shift is just
the income effect.
So that's holding
the prices constant.
The price ratio for bc
prime and bc2 is the same.
But you're now
effectively poorer,
because at the same income
you can afford fewer cookies.
So you're effectively poorer.
So now your income's
effectively fallen.
And at that new
budget constraint
with that new lower effective
income and higher price ratio,
you choose point c.
So we go from a to c, just
like I told you before,
but we actually get
there in two steps.
One step is sort of
the relative change
in prices caused
you to say, ooh,
I want to get away from cookies.
The other say, I'm poorer,
so I want less of everything,
including cookies.
So one is the price effect,
one's the income effect.
And these two effects matter.
Now, in this case,
they don't matter,
because they work together.
In this case, you might say,
well, look, why do I care?
The bottom line is, the
number of cookies fell by 2.
Substitution effect work
together, why do I care?
Well, you might care, because
if the good is inferior, then
the income and substitution
effect work against each other.
If the good is inferior, then
the income substitution effects
work against each other
rather than with each other.
To see this, let's
go to figure 4-6.
Now, we're going to
totally change our example.
Now, we're going to be choosing
between steak and potatoes.
Totally different example--
steak and potatoes.
You start a budge
constraint bc1.
Potatoes are $1,
and steak is $5.
So in our new example--
I'll put this up here--
we've got the price of steak
is $5, the price of potatoes
is $1, and your income is $25.
That's our new example.
In that case, you will choose--
and this is a different
utility function.
This is a totally new example.
I'm not going expect you to
understand the underlying math
here.
I'm just showing an example of
something that might be true.
So you choose point a.
You choose 7 and 1/2
potatoes and 3 and 1/2 steaks
given those prices.
Now, we're going to
say, what happens
if the price of potatoes
goes from $1 to $3?
The price of potatoes goes up.
Well, two things happen--
first of all, the change
in compensated demand
moves you from
point a to point b.
How do we know that?
Because you draw a new
imaginary budget constraint
that has the new
price ratio, but it's
tangent to the old
indifference curve.
So you're point a to point b.
So the substitution
effect lowers your demand
for potatoes from
7 and 1/2 to 4.
But the income effect raises
your demand for potatoes.
Now, the income effect means you
actually move back from 4 to 5.
On net, you're still
having fewer potatoes,
but the substitution
effects went opposite ways.
Why?
Why did the income
effect cause you
to want to have more potatoes?
The substitution, you
wanted have to less.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because the price of
potatoes went up [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Close.
Price of potatoes went up.
So you're effectively what?
Poorer, right?
And when you're poorer, how does
that affect your consumption
of inferior goods?
You want more of them.
So price of potatoes went up.
So effectively you're poorer.
Now, when you're poorer, in our
previous example with cookies
you wanted fewer cookies
than a normal good.
But potatoes are
an inferior good.
So as you're poorer,
you want more of them.
The income effect
goes the opposite way
of the substitution effect.
That's where this starts
to get interesting.
If the income effect
always goes the same way
as substitution effect, this is
sort of just a purely useless
theoretical exercise.
It gets interesting when income
effect goes the opposite way
of the substitution effect.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it
like the [INAUDIBLE]??
JONATHAN GRUBER: Hold on.
I'm getting there.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN GRUBER: Utility-- well
different utility functions
will give you--
you have to have a
different utility function
to get the good to be inferior.
So you utility of steak and
potatoes is not going to square
root of--
you won't get inferiority
with square root of p times s.
So it's a different
utility function,
and I mentioned that I think.
It's a different
utility function.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's the
different functions
that makes potatoes be an
inferior good mathematically.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
So basically, your intuition--
I give you intuition
why they're inferior.
But, mathematically, it
would occur because we'd
have a utility function.
The utility function
would generate
an inferior would be a different
looking utility function.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN GRUBER: Not
off the top of my head.
But we'll do it in section.
So the bottom line is-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you're
setting that price of steak
and potatoes, is it
that they both provide
similar nutritional value?
So one potato does
not necessarily
equate to one steak.
But the price that are
setting, $5 worth of steak
is equivalent, in
terms of my health,
and will fill me up as much as--
JONATHAN GRUBER: No, no, no, no.
I'm not saying that at all.
I'm not writing down
a health function.
I didn't write it down.
This is a utility function.
So it's about filling
up, it's about taste.
Steak may leave me hungrier,
but it's way better.
So it's about what fills me up.
Literally, all I'm saying is,
given my utility function--
and I don't have the utility
function written down--
I was choosing a balance of
mostly potatoes and some steak.
Now that the price
of potatoes goes up,
I end up wanting fewer
potatoes, but not
as few as you might think
from the substitution effect,
because potatoes are inferior.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the price
is more constant [INAUDIBLE]??
JONATHAN GRUBER: No, no.
What I'm saying--
the income effect
is holding the price constant.
What happens to your demand?
So holding the price
constant-- what
I mean by that is moving
from bc prime to bc2
is the income effect,
holding your price constant.
So the price change is
reflecting the substitution
effect.
That's reflected in moving
for bc1 to bc prime.
The income effect is
holding the price constant
that is, given that same slope
of that imaginary new budget
constraint, you're now poorer.
So that's why.
So once again, it's a hard
thing to wrap your mind around.
It's theoretical.
But the notion is when a price
changes two things happen--
it changes the relative
desirability of two goods,
and it changes your income--
your effective income,
your opportunity set.
Two things are happening.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: First, when
the price first changes,
you needed a substitute,
so you keep--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Oh, no.
They both happened
at the same time.
Let's be clear.
This isn't sequential.
This happening in real time.
It's not like you said
the price went up,
I'm going to compute
my, you know--
it's happening in real time.
It's just we're decomposing
into two effects.
And the reason
we're doing that is
because once goods are
inferior, this decomposition
becomes interesting.
So I like to think about this
in sort of a simple table
to help remind you how
to think about this.
So let's think about
a simple table.
Here we have the price change.
so the price can go up
or the price can go down.
Up and down.
Here we have the
substitution effect,
here we have the income effect,
and here, we have the total.
Well, in the case
of a normal good--
if a good is normal--
then we know the substitution
effect when the price goes up
leads you to want
less of a good.
The income effect also leads
you want less of a good.
So you definitely
want less of the good.
These are all equals.
There's always corner cases.
Likewise, when the price
falls, the substitution effect
makes you want more of the good.
When the price falls,
you're effectively richer.
So the income effect makes
you want more of the good.
So you clearly want
more of the good.
That's the easy case.
The more interesting case is,
what if it's an inferior good?
Now, if the price goes up,
the substitution effect
is the same.
Substitution effect
is always negative.
Higher price means you
substitute away from the good.
But the income effect
is now positive.
So the net is unclear.
Likewise, if the
price goes down,
the substitution effect
is always positive.
You always want more of the
good if the price goes down.
But the income effect is now
you want less of the good.
Why?
Because you're richer.
If the price of a good
falls, you're richer.
Richer means you want less
of that inferior good.
So the net effect is unclear.
So the interesting case
becomes inferior goods.
Questions about the table?
So this raises the
question, are there goods--
what does this imply?
If the income effect dominated
the substitution effect,
you could get what?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The higher
prices, the more you buy.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yes.
You could get an
upward-sloping demand curve.
You could actually,
theoretically,
get an upward-sloping
demand curve.
And we call this a Giffen good.
A Giffen good is a good where
you get an upward-sloping
demand curve, where actually
the inferior income effect is
so large it dominates
the substitution effect,
and you actually get an
upward-sloping demand curve--
that a higher price leads
people to want more of the good.
Now, in fact, this is named
after some guy, Giffen,
I guess.
And it probably was a
guy, because it's old.
But, in fact, it's
convenient, because it's
close to where gryphon.
And gryphons are imaginary,
and so are Giffens.
It's actually hard
to find examples
in reality of Giffen goods.
It's actually pretty hard to
find examples from reality.
But there was one interesting
experiment that was run,
which is sort of the
first convincing evidence
that in some situations
Giffen goods could exist.
So I ran the follow experiment.
They run a study in China, where
very, very poor households--
most households
in China are poor,
but they divided it into
super poor versus moderately
poor households.
And they basically
gave them coupons
which lowered the price of rice,
which was their staple good.
Basically, they eat rice, and
that's sort of their basic good
they eat.
And they basically
lowered the price of rice.
What they found is
that for families
that weren't super
poor, they found
a typical downward-sloping
demand curve.
Giving them the coupon off rice
meant they bought more rice.
But for the very,
very poor families,
they actually did find an
upward-sloping demand curve.
Giving them a discount on
the price of rice actually
caused them to have less rice.
Because, literally, that's
all they ever ate, was rice.
So by definition they could've
had more, because they
didn't eat anything else.
Now that you're
essentially saying,
look, you used to eat all rice,
you'd spend your whole budget
right, now I've basically
giving you extra money.
Because all that rice you used
eat, you can now have cheaper.
Are going to spend
that to buy more rice?
No, you're buy something else.
And that's a Giffen good.
So if you think about
sort of a corner solution
where people are buying all
the good that's inferior, then
by definition if you
give them more money,
they're going to move
on to another good.
Or there's at least
a possibility.
And that's the
Giffen good example.
But we have to search
pretty darn hard.
Typically in the
demand context, we
think that demand curves
are downward-sloping.
However, when we get
to other contexts,
we're going to find
it's more normal to find
that these income
and substitution
effects fight against
each other and lead
to strange-shaped curves.
And we'll come back to
that later in the course.
OK, I'll see you all Wednesday.